yeah your mother
when I saw her actually moving in a
mannerism and everything and I said
listen that is me
back then doctors and nurses was held in
such high esteem if they said something
and with compassion they said it in yuba
they do
well there's a simple little law out
that says you can't trafficking human
babies the city of st. Louis owned and
operated hamaji Phillips hospital homer
team Phillips hospital may not be around
but the city of st. Louis they could be
millions I don't think I don't think
that you could quantify the loss of a
baby
for 50 years I got to make up these 49
years and I know the other kids will be
jealous but she's priority not